the reason why companies have men as
Pilots is not because they're racist
it's because more boys want to be a
pilot one day and girls don't what
percentage of nurses same thing with
kids with nurses what percent you can go
on with these questions you can't force
a career upon a kid that doesn't want
the damn job just because you're trying
to bow down to the ESG community and
kiss their asses that's the problem the
L iCal reasonable American people have
we can joke about this all we want it's
no longer funny FAA and it's no longer
funny United Airlines people are sitting
there saying I just want you to get me
from LA to New York get me from Dallas
to Miami that's all I want honestly I
don't care what that person is in there
what nationality they are what
background they are if they're male or
female just prove the results and then
we can sit there and say okay this makes
sense